hello everyone
we're about to get started my name is
bear and i will be your moderator
today's webinar will be presented by dr
joe clayton
who holds a phd in molecular cell and
biomedical sciences
joe is a senior principal scientist here
at biotech a part of agilent
and today he will be discussing tools
and techniques for optimizing
cell proliferation studies before we get
started
i want to mention that we will be
fielding questions at the end of today's
presentation
however you may submit questions at any
time using the chat feature
also all registrants will receive a link
to the webinar's recording via email
once it becomes available
thank you all for joining us today and
with that i'll turn it over to joe
all right thank you very much bear and
thank you everyone for joining us for
this webinar
and uh and greetings from one relatively
isolated scientist
to another i hope you're all staying
healthy and well
recognizing that many of us are kept
away from our labs currently
we've added this webinar as well as a
few more in the coming weeks
to our usual webinar lineup as a way to
provide some hopefully useful
information
in an informal and relatively short
format
while you're at home planning your your
future experiments
we'll cover a variety of topics in these
webinars so stay tuned for future
content
by looking at our upcoming webinar
schedule on biotech.com
i know that over the next few weeks
we've got some fantastic episodes in
our ask the experts series where two of
our fields
application scientists discuss and
present valuable insights and advice
on their fields of expertise
additionally we've got the popular new
ask a scientist series
in which our fas team members present
science concepts geared towards
seven to twelve-year-olds with science
experiments your kids can do at home
however today is all about proliferation
assay so let's go ahead and
get started
so as a as an overview we'll begin by
reviewing the broad range of
proliferation assay formats that are
available
and then discuss some important
considerations for selecting the right
assay format
i'll then cover some general methods and
tips for optimizing proliferation assays
before describing some exciting new
solutions that we've developed for
conducting proliferation
studies all right so that we're all on
the same page
self proliferation refers to an actively
dividing
uh population of cells and changes in
the total number of cells in the
population
resulting from a balance between bold
cell division and concurrent cell death
sensitive and accurate methods for
detecting self proliferation
are critical for a broad range of
applications from basic research
to clinical medicine and proliferation
tools or assays are a useful metric for
evaluating normal developmental
processes
and cell viability and plays a large
role in characterizing malignant cell
behavior
and drug development studies
one way of measuring cell proliferation
is to count the number of
actively dividing cells within a
population or attempt to detect the
telltale signs of cell division within
that population
these methods include the incorporation
and subsequent detection
of nucleoside analogues incorporated
into nascent dna
during during s phase as well as
detecting the presence of cell cycle
specific proteins
such as ki-67
additionally and sort of in a category
of their own
proliferation dyes that permeate cell
membranes and are retained but evenly
distributed to daughter cells
during each division can be used to
profile
the number of cell divisions occurring
within a population
alternatively a large number of assays
are designed to measure the total number
of cells within a population
and more specifically how that number
changes over time
so i've grouped these as both indirect
or
direct methods where indirect methods
attempt to measure
cell number using a metric that is
correlated with cell number
such as total dna or atp levels or the
reducing power of metabolically active
cells
additionally i would put image-based
measurements of confluence
in this category this uses the relative
area covered by cells as a proxy for
cell number
and a variation on this method uses
impedance measurements as a very
sensitive and accurate method
for measuring changes in the total cell
area
methods on the other hand um rely on
actual cell counts
achieved using either manual accounts of
visualized cells
or automated image capture and analysis
of labeled or unlabeled cells
and then alternatively labeled cells can
be counted using a flow cytometer
with the growing recognition of the
benefits of 3d
silk cultures an increasing number of
proliferation methods
are being applied to or optimized for 3d
cell cultures
bright bill imaging can be used to
measure changes in the diameter or
extrapolated volume of a spheroid while
cell labels or specific cell viability
markers
can be employed within a 3d cell culture
to visualize
and measure changes in signal intensity
over time
there are also multiple homogeneous
assays in which the spheroid is lysed
to access cellular contents and live
cell plate reader based kits
to measure amount of viable cells or
cytotoxicity
alright so clearly lots of available
options so how do you select
the appropriate format
so for most researchers one of the most
important considerations for selecting
an assay
or assay format is the instrumentation
that is available
pretty much all of the assay formats
that i've described are run on one of
the instruments shown here
homogeneous assays are read using a
plate reader whether it's
luminescence or fluorescence readout
where cell counting methods rely on some
form of microscopy
either a conventional manual scope or an
automated imaging system
or combination automated imager plate
reader
or alternatively a flow cytometer for
quantification of labeled cells in
suspension is also an option
of course having a combination of these
instruments really opens up
the most options for a researcher
and although for many labs the cost of
reagents will not be a huge deciding
factor in choosing an assay format
it's worth at least considering this
variable especially for labs looking to
conduct a large number of these studies
so this figure is really just meant to
illustrate general trends and reagent
costs
with label-free imaging methods or
impedance methods having no additional
reagent cost
whereas some kits are relatively more
expensive than others
ranging in something like 20 to 60
dollars per microplate
a major fork in the road in terms of
deciding on the the right assay format
is whether to choose an endpoint or
kinetic setup
so if we think of an endpoint assay is
as shown here the general process
consists of seeding cells in a
microplate and adding treatments before
then placing the plates
away in an incubator for some arbitrary
amount of time
at which point then the plate is
retrieved for processing
and reading so this provides just a
single snapshot
in time of the number of cells present
for each sample
in contrast when we compare this to a
kinetic live cell imaging assay for
measuring proliferation cells are seeded
and exposed to treatment
and then continuously monitored to
capture a much greater amount of
information
on how the cell population changes over
time
if we attempt to do a side-by-side
comparison of these two
fundamentally different approaches we
might say that the
relatively simple nature of an endpoint
assay may be a strength
however the simplistic nature of these
assays are the very reason why they
often fall short
they're essentially impossible to
effectively normalize for variations in
starting cell number
additionally they rely on an arbitrary
set time point
and require processing steps that can
lead to reproducibility issues
and preclude any further experimentation
or cell recovery
whereas kinetic acids are much better
suited to effectively measure
changes in cell population size over
time and to normalize results for
accurate interpretation
if you had to assign a fault to these
assays you may perceive the
the multiple required measurements uh as
as requiring more involvement however
the kinetic proliferation assays that
i'll describe
in a bit are fully automated so really
minimizing any hands-on time
so i'd say clearly the winner here would
be a kinetic based
approach
when selecting a cell proliferation
assay format the
type of cells that are being studied
certainly is an important consideration
adherent cell lines are compatible with
with most acid formats
however inherent cell types that tend to
clump or that
have a very flat or elongated morphology
or multinucleate cells these can be
challenging to accurately count using
some imaging based methods
suspension cells in the other hand they
also are amenable to a variety of assay
formats
notably homogeneous and flow based
methods however their characteristics
can make them difficult for methods that
that rely on uptake and retention of
vital stains
additionally these cells need to be spun
down at least temporarily
for imaging purposes and then lastly
primary cells that are
generally less expendable may make cell
terminal methods
less attractive
another factor that needs to be taken
into account is
any likely or potential
treatment-induced effects that would
skew the assay readout
causing misleading results for instance
treatments that
affect metabolic output or changes in
cell morphology
as the example below shows
so here we see how this drug-induced
change in morphology
decreases the accuracy of cell
identification
and then lastly just to note the use of
cell stains even those touted as
non-self-returning can affect
proliferation behavior
in a cell type dependent manner
lastly 3d assay formats present an
attractive alternative to conventional
2d formats
given the ample evidence that they
provide a more biologically relevant
environment
with the potential to generate more
translatable data for clinical studies
however the complexity of 3d systems
that are so desirable for these reasons
also present considerable challenges in
terms of assay reproducibility
and accessibility of cells to achieve
accurate measurements
i'll discuss some of the ways these
challenges can be addressed in the
following
section in which we cover strategies for
optimizing
your proliferation assays
an important component here really
pretty much of any proliferation assay
is starting cell number or cell density
within the well
so assay formats have different levels
of sensitivity that is
that is to say the minimum number of
cells that can be detected as well as
conditional limits for detecting any
further changes in cell number
for instance in the two examples shown
here we see the relationship between
starting cell density
and changes in signal intensity over
time
in these examples you'll see how
starting with cell densities that are
too high
result in sample values plateauing early
within the time course
this prohibits any further meaningful
analysis
so as a best practice optimal starting
raptable
cell density should be determined before
running any experiments
and this allows you to identify a cell
density that is at the lower end
of reliable detection maximizing your
assay window
another important consideration here is
cell distribution
so many experiments suffer from poor
seeding techniques that result in
uneven distribution of cells within the
well this creates
variable growth conditions within each
sample and can cause misleading
and noisy results one simple
technique here is when seating your
microplates
add your cell suspension to the plates
and then allow the cells to settle down
evenly
for about 30 minutes at room temperature
in the hood before transferring them to
the
incubator
um as i mentioned earlier stains which
can be quite useful for identifying
individual cells
and and generating counts can have a
troubling effect on proliferation rates
so this is especially problematic when
the effect is cell type specific
or compounded by an experimental
treatment
here i have illustrated a study done to
evaluate the ability of a range of stain
concentrations
to be reliably detected using image
analysis tools
and then looking at the proliferation
profiles of those cells stained with
each concentration
the results revealed a strong
anti-proliferative effect at stain
concentrations that are often used in
live cell kinetic assays
this process also then allowed us to
identify a concentration that could be
reliably detected
without affecting proliferation rates
over the desired time course
um so as i've described 3d culture
formats can be
a bit of a double-edged sword however
there are some strategies that can make
um or that can be employed to make
proliferation studies within the 3d
system
more reliable
because spheroids are made up of a
considerable amount of cells tightly
clustered together
this can pose considerable challenges
for effectively and
thoroughly processing these samples for
homogeneous assays
to start with confirm that spheroid
volumes are
consistent with reagent guidelines and
allow ample incubation
times for stains or reagents to fully
penetrate the sample
often in my experience this this
required time is is longer than even
stated in the manual but
it certainly requires some level of
optimization
also consider the use of an orbital
shake step to assist in in the
processing of these spheroids
and as the example on the right from
promega demonstrates
reagents specifically designed for the
challenges of
3d structures namely being able to
penetrate into that larger volume
i could do a much better job in terms of
accessing the whole sample resulting in
better signal and
more meaningful results
i've kind of set up a list of
considerations
dedicated to just imaging applications
around 3d
3d studies i'll touch on just a few of
them here but
we will be doing a a focused webinar in
the next two weeks
that are going to really address most of
the considerations are a lot of
considerations around
setting up the 3d biology so
tune in there for for more information
but briefly if if we go through some
considerations
that are important for imaging of 3d
bass proliferation studies
certainly the size of the 3d system is
going to have an effect on
on pretty much everything that is listed
below here
so one one important consideration that
i've mentioned is can the reagents reach
the biology
this is not only the case for larger
clusters of cells larger spheroids but
but the scaffolding that is used or any
potential matrices that
could affect um the the biology getting
exposed to the the stains or reagents
for magnification general guidelines we
tend to use
for a 96 well plate a 4x objective
whereas for higher density plates going
up to 1536 well
we found 10x to be a good pairing for
that cell density
um one thing to note that uh i think
really we can have a whole separate
conversation on is is what is the right
metric to use
although using the volume or the size of
a spheroid is an appropriate metric for
many cases
often people are looking at spheroid
size
when really what they are desiring to do
is measure the the number of cells
present
which is quite impractical i'm using
most techniques
however disassociation methods that i'll
describe in a moment are one approach
for addressing this
this this issue
additionally one thing to think about is
where is the signal coming from
is it equally distributed throughout the
volume or is there a gradient that needs
to be considered
if it's diffuse a single focused capture
may be sufficient
whereas if it varies the whole volume
may need to be
to be captured with z stacking with step
size being dictated by the
depth of field for for each objective
and the last thing i wanted to mention
here in terms of imaging specific
applications with
with 3d systems is um the time involved
and
beyond that you know what is the
acquisition time for read step
this may seem like a trivial
consideration
but when you start putting together read
steps that consist of
multiple images per plane using multiple
channels and adding in z stacking
there will be some really important
implications in terms of throughput
and differential effects across samples
if you're working with live cells
for instance a simple two by two montage
in three channels
with ten z slices and you're looking at
nearly twelve thousand images per each
step
in a ninety six well plate and you know
depending on your imaging system
uh this will take varying amounts of
time but uh pretty much every system
that'll be a considerable investment in
time and and data uh
you know in the order of tens of
gigabytes so
uh you know kind of in the category of
just best practices but
you know really the i think the big
takeaway here is use the appropriate
image capture that
gives you the signal you need without
capturing excessive information that
will be
difficult to manage all right so as i
alluded to an interesting combination of
formats
can also be used that provide the
benefit of 3d cultures
with the single cell resolution of other
techniques
so in the example shown here researchers
monitored
tumor spheroid size and viability over
several days
using live cell imaging and fluorescent
labels before then disassociating the
spheroid
using trypsin and gentle pipetting this
enabled the con
the constituent cells to be
characterized and counted
by either flow analysis or 2d image
cytometry
alright so in this last section i want
to highlight some recent advances in
proliferation assays
and describe a couple of automated
imaging based solutions that we've
developed for conducting these studies
now the heart of our kinetic
proliferation acid is a label-free
method for directly counting cells
this method uses our high contrast
bright field imaging mode
to capture both detailed images of
adherent cells as well as
defocusing techniques uh to produce a
distinct bright signal
that corresponds to each cell and this
is then easily identified by
gen 5 image analysis tools the graph on
the right demonstrates how consistently
these label free counts
line up with cell counts derived using
nuclear labels for identification
um this label-free method provides
accurate and reproducible counts over
a wide range of cell densities and cell
types
generating a detailed profile of changes
in the number of
cells within a population with results
reported in real time
this proliferation assay has importantly
been optimized for both 96 and 384 well
formats
this assay also provides the option of
reporting percent confluence alongside
direct cell counts
as an additional metric for measuring
changes in the size of the population
as well as cellular characteristics
looking at how the kinetic proliferation
assay is set up
cells are seated in the microplate and
then treatments are added
at which point the plates are simply
placed in either the lionheart fx
automated microscope or the citation
cell imaging multimode reader
where onboard environmental controls
provide optimal growth conditions within
the instruments
the kinetic proliferation protocol is
selected with the desired read frequency
and duration
and then images are captured throughout
the experiment with proliferation
results
reported in real time
for higher throughput applications
incorporation of the biospa
automated incubator enables running up
to eight plates in parallel
with each plate gently delivered to the
incubation or to the
integrated citation for each read the
small footprint of this system enables
it to
sit conveniently on a bench top for easy
access
additionally one of our liquid handling
instruments can be integrated with this
system
for a fully automated solution that fits
within a lab hood
recently we introduced our wide field of
view camera as an option for the
citation 5 and citation 7.
this option enables capturing the entire
well area
in a 3 to 4 weld plate with a single
image so this provides a really
efficient way for conducting
proliferation studies
in characterizing proliferation behavior
for a large number of treatments
and replicas and as this matrix view of
results demonstrates
this method generates highly consistent
and reproducible results
in terms of analysis powerful gen 5
tools
provide quantitative analysis that is
used to determine accurate and detailed
evaluation
of dose response from these
proliferation profiles
drug efficacy and ic50 values can also
be reported for specific time points
as shown in the figure on the left or
the integral analysis feature can be
used to account for changes
across a specified duration or interval
as shown in the lower center
and lower right figures with
corresponding ic50 values also reported
now in addition to the overall effect on
proliferation the mechanism of cell
death can be examined
using fluorescent reporters of apoptosis
and necrosis
so using this combined cell
proliferation and cell viability assay
at each time point where bright field
images are taken
to generate the total cell counts
corresponding fluorescence images
are taken of the apoptosis marker pciva
and the necrosis marker pi
and then these cells that are positive
for either of these markers
are identified by gen 5 with counts of
apoptotic and necrotic cells reported
for each time point
the real benefit of this combined
approach is that not only does it report
the
absolute number of apoptotic in necrotic
cells over time
as shown in the figures on the left but
total cell counts derived from the
label-free proliferation assay
can be used to report the number of
apoptotic and necrotic cells
that are relative to the total
population size these are shown in the
figures on the right
so as these figures demonstrate as the
profiles revealed
this metric provides a much more
informative readout of cell viability
and a method for comparing comparing
treatment effects
this detailed characterization reveals a
tremendous amount of information
that would never be observed using a
conventional proliferation essay
certainly not an endpoint assay
as an example here we see that despite
uh nigerian's
efficacy and inhibiting proliferation
seen in the previous figures
the curves in red shows that it resulted
in little apoptosis or necrosis that
even the highest concentrations tested
all right lastly we've developed a 3d
proliferation assay that
like the 2d format i just described uses
a combination of label-free methods to
measure
total self-population size as well as
fluorescence microscopy
to characterize cell health
setting up this assay consists of
seeding cells in a ultra low attachment
microplate
and incubating for one to five days on
average depending on
the cell type typical starting cell
numbers per well range from several
hundred to several thousand cells
depending on the application and
duration of the experiment
given the long-term evaluation that is
typically required for 3-d proliferation
studies
multiple media exchanges are required to
maintain optimal growth conditions
in terms of readout changes in spheroid
volume and fluorescence are detected
throughout the time course typically
using a 4x single field of view
with z-stacking and then depending on
the biology
about a 12-hour capture interval over a
week or two is a good starting point for
setting up these assays
as with the 2d format the 3d
proliferation assay has the ability to
be
fully automated by integrating the
biospa system with a
citation and multiflo fx liquid handler
outfitted with the amx module this
module was specifically designed
to conduct the gentle media exchanges
that are required for 3d
biological systems
a gen 5 analysis identifies the spheroid
area for each time point
indicated by the yellow outlines in this
this panel
chronicling spheroid expansion over time
and then theoretical spheroid volumes
are calculated throughout volumes can
then be
used for comparison across conditions
as with the 2d format this 3d
proliferation assay has been optimized
for both 96 and 384 well formats
and comparing calculated volumes over
time for each sample provides a robust
quantitative method for
um for looking at treatment responses
within a 3d system
and as i mentioned this assay can be
expanded to include detection
and quantification of cell viability
using the broad range of available
fluorescent markers
which will expand on during our next
webinar in a couple of weeks
so in conclusion clearly there are many
available
assay formats to consider for conducting
proliferation studies
the kinetic imaging-based methods that
we've presented here
provide a powerful and versatile
solution for measuring
self-proliferation
but for the most rigorous studies really
it's a combination
of multiple assay formats that is
required
and while biotech offers a diverse set
of instruments that are well suited for
conducting proliferation assays
the citations combined plate reader and
imaging capabilities
optimized for lifestyle studies enables
a broad range of proliferation assays to
be conducted within a single
bedstock instrument
so with that i'll be happy to take any
questions you may have
either now or in in follow-up
and thank you again for your time back
over to you bear thanks
thank you joe for that terrific
presentation um
as joe said we'll now take a look at
some of the questions that came in and
if you haven't done so
i just want to remind you that you can
submit any additional questions
using the chat feature and we'll get to
as many of those as we have time for
okay thanks bear um so we got uh
looks like we've got a lot of great
questions here so let me um
go through these one at a time um
we have a question here what cell types
does the 2d proliferation format work
with
um so this this method has been
validated on a variety
of adherent cell types we do recommend
that you confirm the
the process is accurate with with each
new cell type and we do have a protocol
for doing this it
essentially consists of um seating your
cells uh in question
at a variety of densities and then
adding uh nuclear stains such as hooks
to then confirm that those counts line
up
um certainly cells that clump up
together or tend to
be flat and elongated are less amenable
to
this technique so this is um something
that you'd certainly want to uh
to take into account um
let's see here what else do we have um
when should the complement values be
used
instead of counts um
so confluence can provide really
valuable information on
cell morphology in addition to counts
so if you use confluence in concert with
counts you can
reveal changes in coverage area so
changes in relative
cell size for given counts um
additionally those cell types that are
not amenable to label-free counts
such as those that tend to cluster that
i mentioned before
confluence can provide a really valuable
alternative for
proliferation
i have one here how to avoid
the background problems in 3d um
so the gen5 software has
background subtraction algorithms that
can be applied to
to address this to just this problem to
get a nice clear signal for the
spheroids
so this is all within the the protocol
and we do have recommended protocols
that are available
to folks who are running this type of
assay or others but essentially the
short answer is we do have
background subtraction built into the
software that is really invaluable
in terms of addressing this problem
um what do we have here
um what is high contrast bright fields
so as i mentioned that is used for
our cell counting high contrast
breitbart is a modified form of
breakfast available on
many of our imaging instruments it is a
module that is added on and in the
process it creates
images that provide more detail over a
conventional break field
this is also really important for
quantitative
measurement so we use our high contrast
bright build for a lot of
our quantitative metrics um
including the label-free cell counting
which actually captures two
high-contrast breakdown images
the first is a focused image that
provides maximum
resolution and then a defocused
image which actually generates the
almost binary image where the cells
appear it's a very bright spot that
facilitates
robust counting um can phase images be
used for cell counts
we do not recommend using phase for cell
counting
our instruments many of them are
available with
phase optics and phase clearly takes
beautiful
images for a lot of especially
qualitative
studies and can be combined with any of
the
protocols and procedures that are
described here but
we use high contest brightfield for we
found that to be a much more robust
way to identify cells over over phase
one are cell cycle dependent methods
used versus
methods for total population size
i would say generally speaking the cell
cycle dependent methods
those looking for actively dividing
cells within a population
those are the preferred method for cases
where it's not practical
or necessarily informative to count
total cells so i'm thinking
tissue samples here this is these are
frequently used in histology
and assessing patient samples to be able
to identify within a population of
what should be non-dividing cells the
presence of aberrant
cell divisions versus
most research or studies looking to
understand the basic division rates
of a population of cells that will tend
towards
the latter or using more of a method
described with our
label-free proliferation assay as a more
informative
route
uh how long can proliferation
experiments be run in the lionheart
citation um so i guess maybe to begin
answering that question
um you know kind of flip it around um
you know how long should they be run is
maybe maybe one of the questions
and depending on you know this is really
going to depend a lot on the
the cell characteristics you know what
the division rate is the doubling time
of the population
um i a good rule of thumb would be to
look for
three or so rounds of division that
should provide a pretty good assay
window
in terms of differentiating treatment
effects
that being said you can
run the the plates in the lionheart with
the available co2
uh control temperature internally and
the humidity chamber
for well the humidity chamber is going
to essentially get you up about four or
five days but then at that point it
could be
replenished so the short answer there
would be
it would enable you to run experiments
out probably longer than you
you want to at least for a 2d based
assay
this is similar with the citation in
terms of the available temperature and
gas control however for the citation it
does get coupled with the
biospa for more sustained runs in which
humidity would also be controlled
and again there it's really just a
matter of
how long you have a supply of co2
and keeping the humidity um
tray filled essentially the same
considerations you have within a
conventional incubator it's a bit of a
different answer with 3d based studies
so certainly those are going to on
average go out farther
um one to two to multiple weeks
to really get at changes in size uh
within that structure
in those cases either of those
instruments would be used uh however the
the citation biospa system would be
uh preferable uh because of the the full
automation capabilities that could be uh
incorporated including the liquid
handling
uh question here is it better to use
labels for measuring
um for measuring size of a steroid
versus bright fields so it's better to
use labels for measuring proliferation
or um so this really is going to depend
on your biology
the primary readout is is going to be
the size of a steroid for
3d studies and this is determined by
gen 5 masking with diameter being
determined from
the mask applied to the to the spheroid
with then the option of extrapolating uh
theoretical volume from that assuming
assuming uh
symmetry um you know so so both of these
methods label label-free or fluorescence
are ultimately going to be used to
create that mask to define that
that area so you should expect to see
very comparable results across those two
methods
that being said i would say in many ways
labels
because of the potential impact on the
cells themselves and
potentially changing over time as
staining
flattens out or as the steam may break
down would make
label free more preferable um
one other thing i would add there is
that um as we are defining that spheroid
volume we're putting a mask we're using
our image analysis to define the border
of that volume
important consideration is how does that
volume change um
in maybe treatment-induced ways so this
is not necessarily
caused by changes in the cell number
but by the ability of those cells to
remain tightly packed into a spheroid
structure
so in other words you could likely see a
spheroid starting to break
up as it is being treated
and potentially that could be perceived
as an increase in volume
so one way this can be addressed is by
looking at the average signal or taking
the ratio of uh
signal intensity over the uh the area so
this is one way you can start to
identify
where maybe the the spheroid is breaking
up
instead of instead of actually changing
its size
um someone's asking can they run a
proliferation experiment
on the citation 5 without co2
um yeah the short answer is yes you can
although
you will want to i think make it a bit
more of a manual
process co2 is certainly going to be
essential to maintain
cell viability so in that case in the
absence of
a co2 hookup to the citation 5
you could run what we call a
discontinuous kinetic experiment so in
this case
the plate is red and then returned to
the incubator until the next reset and
then it would just be delivered
in that process moving forward to
continue to get read steps over the
desired
timeline
um how do you do how how can we derive
cell counts from steroid diameter
um the short answer is you really can't
um as i was describing
uh a bit a moment ago with the bright
fields versus label question
um different cells are going to pack
into into spheroids uh
shapes differently um so really what we
are what we are looking at there is is
just um within a given
condition how those those sizes will
change and we are really using
a volume of our cellulite as a proxy for
cell number
for studies that really do want to get
down to that granular detail
of the number of cells that are present
i would recommend um some of the
techniques i described with
this is so disassociating the the
steroids this is really kind of a
it's a powerful technique to get the
best of both worlds where you can get a
kinetic evaluation
of a steroid and the benefits of that
system
but then be able to break it up and
analyze it in much greater detail
for either using image-based methods or
flow cytometry this is also a powerful
technique
to get at if you really want to resolve
cells that are
internal to that spheroid that might not
be detectable with conventional imaging
methods
let's get a couple more here
could we simultaneously check for cell
viability and the proliferation as well
yeah so absolutely so the um the methods
i described there with proliferation
and the um the markers for apoptosis and
necrosis those can absolutely be done in
a single
assay so those read steps essentially
combined and we have
protocols that we can provide
for you that get you started in terms of
the basic setup and steps for doing that
but essentially it consists of the
proliferation read step coupled with
the fluorescent read steps to be able to
identify
the fluorescence in addition to
the actual cell number the total cell
number so that's really the power of
that system is that they are combined
and so that you have the ability to not
only say the number of cells present and
the number that are apoptotic on the
product
but the ratio of those that now allows
for much better comparison of those
samples
all right let's do one more here um
could you review good cell seating
techniques to achieve either
distribution of cells
um so yeah as i mentioned this really is
a critical
readout or sorry aspect of the setup
and the primary way i advise people to
improve this or improve the seating
density is to
want to make sure you have an even
distribution of cells a nice
homogeneous mix of cells or even the
distribution of cells within your
suspension
add an appropriate volume to your to
your wells i recommend about 200
microliters
per 96 well plate um
and letting this is a critical step you
let them just sit
it's hard to to kind of get out of um
maybe maybe conventions but rather than
popping that right into the incubator
let that plate sit at room temperature
in the hood that will allow the cells to
settle down
evenly remaining in that even
distribution and they'll give you a much
more
even layer of cells in your microplate
so after about 30 minutes then you can
you can move that back into the
incubator
um certainly recommend confirming that
so you can actually use
the amenities image analysis tools that
i described and we have some
specific kind of qc protocols that allow
you to go through an entire microplate
and assess
or confirm that you do have even
distribution of cells
before proceeding with the acid so this
is a valuable way to
to optimize an assay before proceeding
as you can imagine the starting number
of cells is really an important variable
in these assays
and can heavily skew the results and the
perceived proliferation rate so getting
that step right really does a lot in
terms of
optimizing results and giving you the
most meaningful
data all right well thank you again for
your time and great questions if there
are any other questions that come in
or ones i didn't get to i will follow up
uh by email
and make sure everybody does get an
answer to the questions and um
please follow up by email afterwards if
you uh if you think of something else
all right thank you joe thanks so much
unfortunately that's all the time we
have for today
and i just want to thank everyone who
joined us um as joe
said if we did not get to your question
that you submitted we'll be sure to
follow up with you in an email
and if you'd like more information about
biotech's products and services
please visit our website at
www.biotech.com
we hope you enjoyed today's presentation
and have a great rest of your day